only memories remain
Ron Ellis died in 1987. but the impact
of his death lives on through his son
mark
who kept his father's HIV a secret for
decades the perceived shame cost him his
health relationships and career but
today unlike others Mark won't be
compensated should have been paid 30
years ago 30 years too late
Ron was one of thousands accidentally
infected with HIV or Hepatitis C through
contaminated blood products between the
70s and 80s
and now by the end of today eligible
families should have up to 100 000
pounds in their bank accounts
currently only living victims or
partners are eligible I'm glad the
infected again
but
I believe that they could have gone
further and they could have paid more
um obviously
the way I put it is um
the dead they paid the ultimate price
this is why Steve has what he calls
survivor's guilt
he's been emailed saying he will be
compensated for his ordeal but some of
his friends won't
they've been you know thrown under the
bus and forgotten about this is decades
that we're talking about here so any
six-figure seven-figure compensation
divide it by the number of decades in
the number of years and it'll give you
an idea of well that's not actually that
much to campaigners compensation is a
start but it's also Bittersweet you've
got a long way to go inquiry will
conclude its hearings in early part of
2023 the blood dying every single week
and not knowing whether they're going to
be included in the compensation and it's
not just about money it's about
acknowledgment of what happened
that's all Mark wants admission
money of course helps but it won't bring
back his father
it will however be one step closer to
Justice sub-achowdery Sky News Swindon